we need the rare earth minerals and
China's gonna be like deal they're going
to go to Russia and OPEC and they're
saying we need oil and they're going to
say deal and the U.S is going to be like
but we shut down Keystone Pipeline and
we we stopped energy production so we
don't make energy we don't make uh raw
materials here anymore we don't Harvest
them we do a whole lot of nothing I mean
look we do some of that stuff in the U.S
but it's way down Trump was trying to
bring back manufacturing and that's
probably why you can see what's
happening but I hope you guys are ready
for a big ride it's going to be fun yeah
Biden is a horrible Diplomat people
don't like him he's mean
um he he was a terrible military
commander he he we he surrendered our
military to the Taliban and Afghanistan
and people see the weakness in the
idiocy and like the old Frailty and they
just don't take him seriously I don't
that's the vibe I'm getting Saudi
Arabians are like you know if there's
anyone we're ever going to cut ties with
in the United States it's Joe Biden that
guy's a dick it's not personality it's
the policies it's it's what what he's
doing that's pushing forward we I could
get in a whole rant about Saudi Arabia